Argenteuil en région parisienne ou un
supermarché
fermé pourquoi parce que les
consommateurs les clients ont dénoncé
des pratiques qui les surprenait c'est à
dire qu'on a retrouvé des déjections de
rats on dit de souris de rats il y avait
en plus des produits périmés en rayon ça
peut vous arriver à qui ça n'est pas
arrivé d'avoir des produits périmés dans
les rayons des supermarchés alors
parfois effectivement les grands
distributeurs ne font pas exprès il y a
quelques produits qui ont été oubliés
d'être enlevés parfois on s'interroge et
c'est pour ça qu'on voulait être avec
Laurent Richier aujourd'hui bonjour
merci d'être avec nous en direct vous
vous êtes un ancien boucher et vous êtes
devenus lanceur d'alerte parce que vous
avez des choses à nous dire et ça
intéresse évidemment ceux qui nous
regardent sur les pratiques
effectivement dans les supermarchés dans
les magasins dans les boucheries vous
êtes un ancien boucher et si je ne ma
vise vous êtes venus végétarien et c'est
pas pour rien pourquoi vous êtes devenu
végétarien d'abord expliquez-nous
végétarien tout simplement parce que
hiérarchie successives m'ont tellement
fait faire de excusez-moi de d'être
péjoratif mais des des cochonneries des
saloperies que à force bah voilà je suis
devenu malheureusement boulimique alors
ici qui est l'avion de me dégoûter au
plus haut point et ce que j'ai fait je
le regrette aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
que j'ai décidé de dénoncer ce scandale
colossal qui se passe dans les usines
dans le dans la grande et dans la
moyenne distribution
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes surpris
par cette affaire de supermarché il y en
a eu d'autres là on en parle aujourd'hui
parce qu'on a vu dans les médias ce
supermarché qui qui ferme ça nous
inquiète tous on va tous faire nos
courses dans des dans des supermarchés
semble-t-il l'hygiène peut parfois être
approximative racontez-nous vous les
coulisses
les coulisses de la boucherie c'est très
simple dans la grande distribution
j'étais intérimaire donc j'ai travaillé
pour plusieurs sociétés je dis sur 10
sociétés il n'y en a pas une qui a
quelque chose à pas se reprocher je vais
vous raconter une année de par exemple
une une fois j'arrive dans un magasin je
retrouve un rat qui est malheureusement
mort sur un plat donc pour indigestion
certainement et moi je préviens le
directeur du magasin
je préviens le directeur du magasin pour
le pour lui dire bon bah qu'il fallait
jeter tout utile et ce directeur me dit
tout simplement non non non surtout pas
on va enlever tout ce qui est
au-dessus du plat et on va laisser voilà
ce que j'ai vécu voilà ce que je vivais
au quotidien retrouver moi des crottes
de souris de rats dans les labos dans
des labos qui étaient vétustes et et ça
m'a mis mais ça m'a mis mais vraiment
hors de moi
mais c'est extrêmement dangereux pour la
santé parce que là on vient de voir
passer une image c'est pour ça que je
faisais une drôle de tête un rat qui
était en train de se promener sur sur
des tartes ou des quiches en
l'occurrence dans une boulangerie les
boulangeries aussi on va faire aura vous
dites en boucherie c'est la c'est la
même chose mais c'est extrêmement
dangereux c'est à dire que des rats qui
se promènent sur sur de la viande ou sur
un plat ça véhicule des maladies
potentielles et ça vous vous votre cas
la personne qui était responsable s'en
fichier
de toute façon moi je vais vous dire moi
rien de m'étonne plus rien mais vraiment
plus rien ne m'étonne tout simplement
parce que
dans une société par exemple bio c'est
enfin bio on va dire une vie une société
renommée pour vendre du super frais
une fois je lève les les plateaux je
retraite des oui il y a la viande je
retrouve des cafards et c'était des des
des crottes de souris et de rats pour
retrouver en permanence dans le magasin
et ils ont appelé deux fois la
dératisation et en fait bon bah ça n'en
finissait pas c'était infesté de rat
mais on en est là aujourd'hui dans la
grande distribution et c'est pour ça que
j'ai voulu être lanceur d'alerte parce
qu'il y a un énorme problème d'hygiène
dans
bout de grandes Richie expliquez-nous
comment on en arrive là comment dans la
grande distribution alors c'est pas
toute la grande distribution évidemment
mais comment on peut en arriver là c'est
à dire que les responsables ne sont pas
regardant c'est pas nettoyé d'où vient
le problème
ça vient tout simplement des des
hiérarchies ça vient des chefs bouchés
et de certains directeurs que j'ai
rencontrés qui ont laissé aller
absolument incroyable si eux pour faire
du billet sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi parce que bon c'est rare qui lui
des dans les bouchers qui nettoient je
veux dire son son étal c'est lui qui
nettoie sans laboratoire mais bien
souvent c'est fait à la va-vite et en
fait
alors on vous a perdu on a un petit
problème de connexion je sais pas si si
vous nous entendez on va peut-être
rétablir
alors on parle de la boucherie mais ça
concerne pas que la boucherie pas que le
rayon boucherie semble-t-il envoyer des
rats qui se promenaient sur des fruits
également
ça me concerne moi quand je travaillais
dans la grande distribution les
boulangers vous savez que les rats sont
vraiment affectionnent la farine combien
de boulanger se plaignaient
qui avait des nuisibles et des rats dans
dans leur laboratoire également mais
mais ça c'est un problème colossal et en
fait les les grandes distributions ne
font rien pour y remédier absolument
rien et ils sont des contrôles internes
en disent oui oui on est contrôlé nous
tout on est contrôlé tous les
tous les deux jours tous les trois jours
tous les jours mais c'est pas vrai ce
sont des contrôles internes ce n'est pas
la DDPP la direction départementale à
protection des personnes qui vient
vérifier ou autrement il faut qu'il y
ait une dénonciation mais ils sont
tellement peu nombreux tellement peu
nombreux à la DDPP et c'est pour ça que
je mène ce combat je le mène et je veux
le mener jusqu'au bout et c'est pour ça
que j'ai écrit ce livre mais alors
Laurent peut-être que ceux qui nous
regardent s'inquiètent
des trucs mais absolument incroyable de
la sciure de de ce qui était pas nettoyé
depuis des semaines et des semaines mais
ça c'est pour que le client
soit vraiment sécurisé dans son achat il
faut il faut absolument que le boucher
élégant je les places soit propre que
tout soit nickel il a le droit de
demander aussi la traçabilité des
produits qu'il achète il a le droit de
demander où la bête a été tuée ou je
vais dire la béthète ou je vais dire où
est la vécu mais mais ça les bouchers
ils répondent ils répondent vraiment
très rarement clairement parce que de
toute façon il y a tellement de
magouilles dans ce métier et je fais un
deuxième livre et j'ai recueilli des
témoignages et vous savez ce que j'ai
retenu en témoignage et là je vais vous
faire de la mort aux rats madame
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu l'épreuve avant de
l'écrire sur mon prochain bouquin de la
mort au rats madame trop de viande pour
faire que la viande soit plus rouge oui
madame on en est là aujourd'hui dans la
grande distribution alors attendez c'est
très grave ce que vous dites Laurent
c'est très très grave ce que vous dites
de l'amour moi pour rendre la viande
plus rouge mais c'est à dire c'est une
pratique courante c'est un fait très
isolé
ça paraît bien de la mort aux rat dans
de la viande c'est c'est dangereux on
finit à l'hôpital non bah ça c'est isolé
c'est des cas isolés mais il y a
certains il y a certains chefs boucher
il y a il y a un certain
directeurs de magasins qu'on n'ont rien
à faire et aujourd'hui la
surconsommation est tellement importante
et l'inflation que si elle va faire elle
va accélérer le processus de la rombale
parce qu'il va falloir avoir le moins de
paires possibles est-ce que vous savez
déboucher on déprime sur le rendement et
sur la perte moins on l'a vu dans le
dans l'affaire Bitoni on l'a vu dans
c'est très intéressant il y a 1200
produits vous parliez de la ferme
bétonie qui ont été rappelés en 2023
1200 produits là on est plus dans la
grande distribution là c'est l'industrie
qui est mise en cause et on a le
sentiment alors peut-être à tort que le
nombre de rappels se multiplient ces
derniers mois et ces dernières années
est-ce que c'est vrai mais bien
évidemment suffit d'aller sur un site
qui s'appelle rappel.gouv et moi j'ai un
Tik Tok et je peux vous dire j'ai une
vidéo qui a été vu un million 500 mille
fois que ce réseau social m'a carrément
viré alors que je prévenais qu'il y
avait des stats Charal qui était rappelé
parce qu'on avait retrouvé les chiens
colis dedans celle qui a tué les enfants
deux enfants j'ai Bitoni et qui en a
paralysé un compte autre c'est une honte
manifeste et aujourd'hui c'est plus de 6
7 10 produits qui sont rappelés dans la
grande distribution et dans les usines
agroalimentaires et je me bats contre ça
c'est un vrai des problèmes c'est comme
le problème de l'élevage intensif on
prévoit d'ici 2050 savez-vous madame 10
millions de décès par an parce que les
animaux sont nourris aux antibiotiques
on leur fait bouffer n'importe quoi on
les transporte par des chaleurs inouïe
c'est des bêtes qui sont malades et
c'est des produits que vous trouvez en
tête de gondole en tête de gondole en
promotion voilà et on vous dit de ces
français et même les labels même les
labels j'ai vu des trucs incroyables
dans les produits labellisés donc qui
disent pas ouais on achète la belle on
est tranquille ce n'est pas
même avec le label rouge alors
effectivement je comprends que vous
soyez devenus végétarien parce que là
vous nous écrivez un paysage
apocalyptique juste une question Laurent
vous dénoncez dans votre livre
effectivement et vous en prenez à la
grande distribution notamment au secteur
de la boucherie au secteur de
l'industrie vous avez pas des menaces
alors Julie menaces de mort j'ai eu des
menaces j'ai des dépôts de plainte que
j'ai fait j'ai fait plusieurs dépôts de
plainte à la police
j'ai été agressé dans une grande surface
voilà j'étais agressé une fois dans la
rue où on m'a dit que j'étais un fou et
que je racontais n'importe quoi
n'empêche que les faits sont là c'est
comme un jour dans un magasin où je
travaillais dans une moyenne surface
très connue il y avait la salle menelle
dans les rayons et le chef n'a jamais
voulu retirer les produits elle s'était
les poulets qui étaient polonais qui
venaient de Pologne et on sait que la
Pologne la Roumanie compagnie ne
maîtrise pas je vais dire les bactéries
et aujourd'hui il a fallu que je supplie
j'étais en congé ce jour-là il a fallu
que je supplie un ami bouché pour
retirer ses produits du rayon on en est
là aujourd'hui on en est là juste un
conseil si on veut manger de la viande
dans des conditions de sécurité maximale
comment comment s'y prend ton
privilégier le circuit court le circuit
court
parisienne pardon Laurence extrêmement
compliqué c'est vrai que quand on est en
région c'est peut-être plus facile de
connaître son boucher d'avoir des des
vaches qui viennent du pré à 10 km en
région parisienne c'est très compliqué
comment fait-on
écoutez je crois qu'il faut prendre soit
le métro la voiture se diriger chez vous
ou alors aller chez votre boucher mais
tout le monde
a pas les moyens vous me disiez
l'inflation du monde n'a pas les moyens
chercher de la viande à 20 km et ben
vous avez si vous avez à Paris par
exemple vous habitez la région
parisienne vous avez un boucher je vous
connaissez bien dans lequel vous avez
une entière conscience à ce moment-là il
y a aucun souci vous allez le voir vous
lui demandez où la bête a vécu ou elle a
été tuée dans quel abattoir et et basta
et là à ce moment-là vous avez
privilégié le circuit court il y a
personne et c'est là que je dis que
c'est super important la confiance dans
votre boucher même si je suis végétarien
moi parce que je me suis juré de ne plus
jamais manger de viande mais il faut
aujourd'hui prendre conscience qu'il y a
un énorme problème dans la grande et
moyenne distribution et j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu et je veux être reçu par
Monsieur Edouard Leclerc promis parlait
de ses franchisés qui trop souvent son
importe quoi et comme toutes les
surfaces qui et j'ai voulu et je lui ai
envoyé des mails et j'attends tout
simplement sa réponse parce que bon la
question à Michel Édouard Leclerc on va
lui poser la question et peut-être
apporter des réponses une toute dernière
chose est-ce qu'il y a d'autres produits
sur lequel il faut que nous
consommateurs soyons particulièrement
vigilant là on a beaucoup parlé de la
viande parce qu'il y en a d'autres et
plat préparé tout simplement les plats
préparés qui sont en usine dans les
usines agroalimentaires où on vous met
des exhausteurs c'est-à-dire des
ingrédients de manière à rendre les gens
beaucoup plus addict beaucoup plus voilà
pour les enfants surtout et voilà donc
c'est tous les produits aujourd'hui qui
sont attaqués c'est le le on parle de
l'avion on parle de la boulangerie de la
pâtisserie moi j'ai un témoignage d'un
boulanger dans mon prochain livre le
gars il fait des pudding avec du pain
qui traînent par terre on en est là
aujourd'hui vous en avez la preuve de ça
alors comment on en a la preuve de ça on
en a la preuve tout simplement parce que
vous savez moi je suis un ex boucher
mais aujourd'hui je suis blacklisté bien
évidemment par toutes les grands des
moyennes surfaces et vous savez quand on
est on sort d'alerte c'est jamais facile
hein c'est des menaces c'était bon c'est
une situation financière qui se dégrade
mais moi j'ai voulu j'ai voulu par
rapport aux réseaux sociaux prendre les
témoignages de beaucoup de personnes de
boucher de boulanger de poissonniers
dans la poissonnerie il se passe des
choses aussi incroyables et quand je
parle aussi euh là je vais changer un
peu de sujet la viande maturée il y aura
un jour un mort dans la viande maturée
parce que la grande surface je te dis
les bouchers se dispatchplorateurs mais
maturateur est un vrai métier la viande
matinée elle est vraiment à il faut
exclure de la viande maturée en grande
et moyenne surface
on se demande mais qu'est-ce qu'on peut
enfin ce qu'on peut manger des pâtes ou
peut-être non je veux vous dire ce que
je veux vous dire je vais vous dire le
mot de la fin c'est mon combat et vous
avez raison
vous vivez quoi aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
plus ou moins cher la terre en concert
qui n'est pas généralisée le jour elle
se généralisera ça va la nature va nous
tomber sur la figure je peux vous dire
vous vivez quoi aujourd'hui en un mot
vous êtes plus boucher vous vivez de
quoi
chômage
voilà tout simplement et et je fais une
formation j'attaque une formation pour
être chauffeur routier aujourd'hui parce
que voilà parce que et puis je suis
dégoûté mais j'étais rien je pourrais
plus travailler dans ce milieu parce que
quand je recueille des témoignages ce
prochain bouquin mais je suis mais on
marche sur la tête ils sont pas comme
c'est pareil attention il faut pas
mettre tout le monde effectivement dans
le même panier voilà et c'est les propos
que vous tenez n'engage que vous bien
sûr c'est important de le rappeler
Laurent Richer merci en tout cas d'avoir
répondu à nos questions